i watch the show it's intense it's
gritty and it's quite the departure for
you especially I feel like what was it
like to be a part of this and to take
this on it was a it was a real dream
come true I mean this is everything that
I've always wanted to make is everything
that this show is just matter is very
heavy what did you learn about yourself
and about our youth making this island I
learned a lot about myself I sort of had
to readjust and make myself like a blank
canvas I suppose coming into playing the
character because he's so different to
who I am as a person so I learnt I mean
I learned a world of stuff in the last
year definitely how did you have to
prepare for some of those really intense
roles I mean even in the first episode
we see you kind of go at it in the
kitchen and it's crazy would you do to
prepare for stuff like that I had like a
little journal and I mean I kind of I
mean it takes it took a very long time
but it was kind of I just kind of got
myself into a headspace for the year and
kind of just lived and stayed in that
headspace so I could snap in and out of
it
how was it working with miss zendaya it
was amazing I mean I'm a massive fan so
I when I found out that she was gonna be
in the show I was pretty stoked she's a
she's she's brilliant she's beautiful
and she's she's a wonderful performer
and she just captain's the ship
perfectly had you signed on before she
did alright yeah I think I was I think I
was one of the first or the first person
cast in the show but I think they'd been
in talks with her and then when they
told me it was probably gonna be her I
was like lost my mind I mean yeah this
is pretty amazing
what about knowing that Drake is behind
this I mean he's the EP of the show yeah
we didn't we didn't know for the longest
time we were shooting the show and then
we kind of found out when the internet
found out and then he dropped by set and
he's a real gentleman and just like a
real stellar person so I was very
exciting again you know did you have a
chance to have a conversation with him
no you just talked about he didn't know
his Australian which was quite cool you
know it means that the accent worked and
yeah that was that was the basis of our
combo I gotta ask you quickly about
kissing booth to what can you tease
we're very excited absolutely nothing oh
yeah
[Music]